let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
well good hump day
it's wednesday
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern you know what time that is
it is time
for let's talk
the tony michaels podcast we have a lot
to talk about today as we do every
wednesday
as we do
every wednesday especially wednesdays on
the night before
when the texas gop
the
christian american taliban hangar
brigade
tries to completely dismantle and
succeeds in texas
to dismantle roe v wade so we're going
to talk about that today of course
i'm going to go over that
uh we're also going to talk about the
the the final
speech that biden gave on the exit
in the war of afghanistan in the
evacuation process
so we're going to talk about that today
because that's in the news that's big
news
we're also going to talk about the
al-qaeda generals in congress
you know who i'm talking about kevin
mccarthy mo brooks
uh paul gozar marjorie taylor greene
matt getz jim i don't report sex crimes
jordan
you know all the good ones
and how
their records
their records phone records phone logs
text logs calls logs
it seems like
it seems like the january 6 select
committee
is gonna get their hands on them and
they're [ __ ] terrified i mean
absolutely
terrified i can only imagine why
that they're terrified my my guess is is
that there's all kinds of juicy [ __ ]
inside these records
uh we had mo brooks i think it was on
newsmax early went oan today this
afternoon
talking about probable cause and how
probable cause doesn't allow them so
we're gonna talk about that too
uh the other thing i wanna touch on
because this kind of got uh
hidden in the shuffle
under the folds here
of afghanistan and the texas law but
rand paul
said something about ivor mexton and the
hatred of trump the other day so i wanna
i wanna talk about that too
but first things first i don't know if
you guys have
been watching my twitter feed but i've
been doing something new the last few
days um which is um it's kind of weird
to me i i wasn't understanding what
twitch was you guys have known this for
the last couple months we stream on
youtube now we also stream on twitter
but we stream on twitch as well and i
had no idea what the hell twitch was i i
thought it was like a gaming thing
and apparently it is mainly gaming but
we started to stream the podcast over
there um so that it was available
someplace else for someone to see if
they wanted to get on twitch so
we've been streaming the podcast on
there for a while this is episode number
35.
35 episodes uh usually one a week we've
had a couple weeks where we had two with
the guest episodes
but i started to uh think about twitch
and what that thing was and how it
worked and i i went and explored a
couple other accounts and i was like oh
oh
it's it's like a like a thing that you
can go and commentate
uh on something that you're searching on
the internet or commentate on a game
that you're playing or something like
that so i was like oh okay so maybe what
i'll do
is i will
i will surf twitter
and live stream it on twitch it's kind
of weird it's a roundabout way so i'm
i'm i'm
surfing twitter
but on twitch it's very strange but
that's what we're gonna do over there so
if you're on twitch if you're out there
if you have a twitch account or if you
don't have a twitch account
go ahead and download the app if you
want if you want to watch me
uh surf twitter and give you it's a
little more casual than it is here on
the podcast here on the podcast we have
certain subjects that we're talking
about that i want to talk about and then
we talk about those subjects
but when i'm doing twitch i'm just kind
of just rolling with the punches just
like i normally do
when you guys don't see me doing it when
i'm tweeting and things like that so
check that out
go to twitch if you're not there already
and uh uh follow my channel there of
course you can find it
um
on twitch just search the tony michaels
or go to thetonymichaels.com
or you can go to my twitter page i
actually put the link up at the very top
and
on my twitter page and speaking in the
twitter page we now have a podcast
twitter page it's at
tony michael's pod
you can find that also at the top of my
my regular twitter profile so that's
we now that we have that business out of
the way let's talk about our
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
um so
i want to start with the rand paul story
because
you know it again it kind of got
snuck under the shuffle here no one
everyone paid attention for
you know a half a day
and he was trending because basically
the what rand paul was saying is is that
there's something to this ivermectin
thing this i remember in this horse base
thing boy it's it's got potential
potential to what poison your dumb ass
yeah of course if that's what you're
looking to do
but he says the reason why no one will
research it that scientist and the
pharmaceutical or whatever whoever the
[ __ ] he's talking about they this is the
thing they do all the time
the republicans the gqp
that
the q anon manga trump hump and
evangelical spread knicks
they're always saying they they they
so he says the reason why they won't
research ivermectin is because of the
hatred of trump
what the [ __ ] does trump have to do with
ivermectin and really honestly if trump
wanted ivermecton researched he would
have done sent out a [ __ ] stupid
statement for all his lackeys to tweet
out an image of and and how he would
have been talking about ivor mikton last
year when he was talking about
hydroxychloroquine
when his supporters were drinking fish
tank cleaner
so i mean i guess i guess when you're
eating horse paste you wash it down with
the fish tank cleaner i guess i don't
know and then you know maybe take a shot
of bleach or inject it or something
it's [ __ ] really confusing and the
reason why it's really [ __ ] confusing
is because you mons are going to a feed
store and buying horse medication
the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
ivermectin is a drug ivermectin is owned
by merck which is one of the largest
pharmaceutical companies in the in this
[ __ ] country and they're putting out
releases saying hey don't take this [ __ ]
for covid not a good idea not a good
idea
to take [ __ ] horse paste ivermectin
for covet it's not proven we haven't
researched it it's a really stupid
[ __ ] idea and all the research and
studies that you've seen online that's
all [ __ ] all of it from the doctors
down to the [ __ ] [ __ ] that they're
typing out it's all [ __ ] horseshit
or [ __ ]
something they know something about here
recently
but rand paul the reason why rand paul
says this let me tell you why rand paul
politically
is saying this because rand paul wants
to run and win again right
and he knows that he has to get all
these [ __ ] trumpets the q and maka
trump humpers the spread necks all
[ __ ] riled up
all riled up
and the best way to do that the the best
way to do that is to get them to believe
that the reason why us libtards and the
libtard pharmaceutical companies them
libtard capitalists don't want to do the
research
is because they hate donald trump
because there's one thing rand paul
knows here there's one
[ __ ] thing rand paul knows if
you're [ __ ] stupid enough if you're
[ __ ] dumb enough if you are [ __ ]
ignorant enough to drive down to the
feed store
and buy a bunch of [ __ ] horse paste
and then sh and ingest it so that you
can stave off or help your covid that
you're currently testing positive for if
you're dumb enough to [ __ ] do that
you are [ __ ] dumb enough to support
donald trump
that's what rand paul knows here
that's why rand paul is saying the
reason why
the the libtard capitalist drug
companies don't want to do the research
so that they can sell and make profit
to covered patients
is because they hate trump
that's it so they type it out on
facebook hey uncle ned did you hear the
reason why that libtard pharmaceutical
company won't make profit off of us is
because they hate trump give me a
[ __ ] break
if merck had any any inclination at all
i mean even just a [ __ ] smidge
of inclination that they could make a
mountain of [ __ ] profit off
ivermectin because it's a covet
treatment they would have been looking
at that [ __ ] a year and a half
ago you stupid [ __ ]
where do you think regeneron or in
disavir came from
they're drug companies that own these
[ __ ] drugs
and they want to make profit
we're a [ __ ] capitalist country where
did you [ __ ] go
what [ __ ] planet are you on anymore
you don't even know what the [ __ ] you
believe
listen you're not owning the
pharmaceutical company either by taking
horse paste
oh we're really gonna go around and
circumvent that big pharma
that big pharma we're gonna circumvent
them and we're gonna take us some horse
pace that way they don't get the profit
and we don't get sick
dumb [ __ ]
it's merc that makes it you stupid
bastards
it's a big pharmaceutical company that's
making the [ __ ] that you're eating
your peanut butter and ivermectin
sandwich you stupid bastard what the f
who the [ __ ] you think makes drugs
do you think do you say do you think
there's [ __ ] human drug companies and
animal drug companies you are a dumb
[ __ ]
you people have lost your [ __ ] minds
you can't you can't even [ __ ] do a
simple google search anymore
and when you do do a google search the
only thing you look for is for something
that that supports your narrative that
way you can go
comment on uncle ned's post on horse
pace dosage
folks we're about a half [ __ ] step
away from being
half brains in this [ __ ] country our
education system has [ __ ] failed us
and so has i
so has our mental health care system we
have none we [ __ ] have none
who are these [ __ ]
oh that's right they're american taliban
right wingers
religious fundamentalist
they will believe anything that the the
religion tells them to believe
and rand paul knew
rand paul knew that their religion
their religion has nothing to do
with patriotism it has nothing to do
with freedom
nothing to do with rights or liberty
it has everything to do with
authoritarianism
crystal fascism
trumpism
you [ __ ] spread knicks
that's enough
all right i think i've ranted long
enough on rand paul and iver mekton does
that make sense though what i'm [ __ ]
saying
about the the ivormectin and the drug
companies and they still haven't i mean
they got it all turned around not just
not just them taking the [ __ ]
it ain't the stupid the stupidest part
isn't i mean it is pretty [ __ ] dumb
for them to think that they can go into
a feed store and there's a [ __ ] cure
sitting there on the shelf that big
pharma is manufacturing and that they
would love to make profit off of if it
was an actual treatment for covid
i mean covet is running rampant around
the rural areas why the [ __ ] wouldn't a
big pharmaceutical company like merck
want to make a [ __ ] ton of money off
this
you [ __ ] boneheads
the best part
this has got to be the best part though
is
when a person because i've been thinking
about this a lot i think i even i
brought it up last week the best part is
when an actual horse owner
has to go in and has to provide because
of these dumb [ __ ] has to
provide a horse passport because
apparently some of these stores are like
no you can't just buy this [ __ ] off the
shelf you actually have to prove to us
that you're a [ __ ] horse owner so
they have to have a horse passport as it
were so not only are these [ __ ]
idiots causing us to have to have
vaccine passports not to fly on planes
get on trains get on a bus go in a
concert but now we're having to have the
people who own horses that actually need
to deworm their [ __ ] horse
the horse do you want to buy the horse
dewormer have to provide a [ __ ] horse
passport
don't you see what you [ __ ]
chuckleheads are doing it's you that are
doing this with your [ __ ] bonehead
agree
jesus [ __ ] christ
and we got a lot of boneheaded read to
go around
some more boneheadedness that we've got
going around is about this exit of this
afghanistan war
you remember this one remember the war
we were in like 20 years you remember
that you remember that america have you
forgot yet
it won't be until next week or maybe the
week after and everyone will forget [ __ ]
everyone forgot we were in it why we
were in it
no one was paying attention to the
afghanistan war
[ __ ] you can't even get these people to
put a simple [ __ ] mask on so you
don't get them sick
so you don't get other people sick you
think these people are paying attention
to the war in afghanistan they can't
even point afghanistan out on the map
joe biden comes out
and gives his final speech
on the exit of afghanistan
and the evacuation process that took
place there which is one of the largest
uh evacuation operations ever in the
history of the world
i don't know the exact number
that they finally got out
but it's upwards to 150 000 people
now there are still some americans over
there some by their own choice
some because of their own stupidity uh
decided to be over there tucker carlson
was talking about this last night some
students went over there from california
uh and they've gotten stuck there which
joe biden even said yesterday in his
speech which
i'm gonna get to a speech here in a
minute but these students he said look
hey hey
we warned you we warned you 19 times
since march
and the thing is
is when an american citizen goes to a
foreign country the embassy our embassy
the american intimacy does not make them
register that they're in that country so
it's not like anyone knew exactly how
exactly how many [ __ ] americans were
in that country and who they were
they didn't know unless they contacted
the embassy they contacted the embassy
then they knew that those americans were
in that country
well
it would
behoove you if you were in a war torn
country especially if there was a civil
war brewing and the american the
american military was going to leave
it would probably be a good idea to
contact the embassy and say hey if [ __ ]
goes down i'm here
you would think
now
there's always going to be americans in
afghanistan
it's not going to be like we're going to
get every single american out of
afghanistan
you're not you're not ever going to get
every single american out of afghanistan
you're some of them are dual citizens
some of them want to live there
i mean they may have their reason i
don't know
i mean what's the reason why you live in
the state that you live in the town that
you live in
you pick that town you live there
your life's there
maybe that's the way they feel
so leave them the [ __ ] alone
and then it's really rich
when we have the numbers of the
evacuation
again
the evacuation on a scale that
was really probably unimaginable before
it actually happened i mean i don't
think the administration or anybody
really realized how many people would
want to leave in such a hurry
because the taliban today were getting
reports that the taliban was was helping
people out the taliban now they weren't
always but these checkpoints some of
these taliban were making sure that
americans got to the airport to get them
the [ __ ] out of the country
now we can't really
you know it is an olive branch but we
got to be real careful not to get hit by
the olive branch switch here
the taliban is really not to be trusted
um and i know we will have plenty of
hearings on this there's going to be
plenty of congressional hearings
in this administration and possibly in
the next administration uh whoever that
is
after this four years if it's still joe
biden uh the next congress and the
congress after that
it's 20 years of war
and it was a lot it's about two years of
unwinding it the deal that trump made
with the taliban and then joe biden
implementing the deal that donald trump
made
so there's a lot of components to this
thing that are going to be looked at
through congressional investigations so
we're gonna find out a lot of these
facts what's [ __ ] what's not what's
real
what actually happened with the deal
what that deal was supposed to be that
trump made
and then how well or how bad the joe
biden administration and the pentagon
the military actually implemented that
deal
we're gonna find all that out
but you know how much americans are
gonna give a rat's ass about that
americans didn't even really
they weren't
even paying attention that we were in
the war in the [ __ ] first place
that is why america the american people
kept voting for presidents that wanted
out of that [ __ ]
whoa who would have thought that
joe biden said in his speech which was
the best speech on a afghanistan war
exit that i've ever heard because it's
the only one
it's the only afghanistan war exit
speech that has been told
and it's been 20 [ __ ] years
there was always speeches about how we
were gonna surge
there was always broken promises about
what you were gonna do
but joe biden laid it out yesterday and
joe biden said hey i [ __ ] told you
when i was campaigning i was gonna get
out of that [ __ ] and that's what
i did
now
there might have been a few flubs here
and a few flubs there
and yeah we still have some americans
over there that we still have to
evacuate possibly
with some special operations
but if those americans want to come home
we will go get them and we will work
either diplomatically or through a
special operation to get those folks
that's what he said
same way with afghanis that have worked
with the military and the united states
government this 20 years same way
and if you don't think if you don't
think that this administration the dod
in the pentagon is going to continue to
do everything they can do along with the
state department
to get the people out that want out of
that country you have not been paying
attention
you have not been paying attention to
how many [ __ ] people left that
country
donald trump and stephen miller's plan
was to leave those people to [ __ ]
slaughter
they were not going to get any afghans
out of that country
they were going to let the taliban have
their [ __ ] way with them
they've all but said that out loud
we don't wanted him afghans in our
country oh my god you mean lamb afghans
you mean are you gonna leave them there
with the taliban
well we can bring them here jethro i
done told you i don't want them brown
people here
which is it
which is it
do you want out of the war or do you not
want out of the war are you sad about
the afghans are you not sad about the
afghans are you really broken up about
the the women and the young girls there
are you not when you're [ __ ] passing
laws to make texas the [ __ ] american
afghanistan
you [ __ ] boneheads
so i guess maybe we'll get to that now
now that i'm on that subject
so last night in the middle of the night
the texas gop
the
american
christian
taliban
the hangar brigade
decides it's a good idea for women's
rights in this country to put bounties
on their heads
women who may need
or want to seek advice on abortions
now it's very unclear at this point this
is all really kind of new and this law
is really [ __ ] stupid obviously it's
[ __ ] stupid it takes away
every every every woman in the state of
[ __ ] texas and anyone who wants to
help that woman in the state of texas
with their healthcare choice it
basically puts a [ __ ] bounty on him
and takes their [ __ ] liberty away
they're always talking about cancel
culture and liberty and rights my body
my choice we've heard this for a [ __ ]
year and a half these [ __ ]
but now now in texas by god
if you
if you get pregnant and you get past six
weeks which
90
of abortions that even still happen in
this country
85 90
happen after six weeks because you don't
even i'm not a woman
that's why i'm not gonna tell a [ __ ]
woman what to do
especially especially
with her [ __ ] uterus
but most women don't even know they're
[ __ ] pregnant
till after six weeks that seems
intentional don't you think
so any woman
past six weeks not only the woman
her family
the doctor
the person that could possibly drive her
to
the procedure to get an abortion
now has a 10 000 bounty on their head
from anyone
anyone not the government and that's how
they get around this that's their little
loophole here is what they're saying is
the state of texas isn't punishing you
the state of texas isn't punishing you
the state of texas has nothing to do
with it
we just have a little law here that
makes it legal for someone to sue you
because they want to
and it's a bounty because you have to
pay that person 10 000 plus legal fees
and the state says we're not involved at
all wink
so essentially and and it's very unclear
to me
uh
what the particulars
of this ten thousand dollar bounty is
but in my mind
if you can if someone has or has had or
sought out an abortion or or helped one
someone
to go to a clinic
rather it be in texas or another state
and that's where the danger is here
that's where the [ __ ] danger is here
is that a woman in texas has lost her
complete liberty of her [ __ ] uterus
because she can't she can't go to
another state well i mean if if if her
friend they get in a car and they go to
another state
and she receives an abortion and she
comes back while her neighbor knows that
she's a citizen of texas and she had an
abortion
so wouldn't you think that that person
would sue them for the legal fees in the
ten thousand dollar bounty
that the person has to pay plus the car
driver person is going to get 20 000 now
i don't know if it's ten thousand
dollars altogether or if it's ten
thousand dollars of whack you know each
person
but this seems really dangerous when you
have
when you have women citizens of texas
losing the liberty of their uterus
a liberty that other women in other
states have it seems to me
that that alone
that alone
is against the constitution of the
united states of america
now the problem that we have is susan
collins little promise that brett
kavanaugh wouldn't destroy roe v wade
well brett kavanaugh's got a little
alibi here i didn't destroy roe v wade
all's i did was do nothing it was the
state of texas fault
it's time to [ __ ] pack the courts
folks
that's what it's time to do
it's it's time
to [ __ ] pack the courts
and i don't give a [ __ ] how you do it
democrats
don't give two
[ __ ]
you just pack those [ __ ]
and it's time we get rid of that
filibuster all [ __ ] together
because mitch mcconnell
he didn't give a [ __ ] about the
filibuster didn't give two [ __ ] shits
about it
when getting the federal judges are
getting the supreme court judges and
ramming them down our throats that way
women in texas and god knows whether the
[ __ ] state is going to use this model
women all across this country lose the
[ __ ] liberty to their goddamn uterus
their [ __ ] body
not a simple [ __ ] mask that you put
on your face
to make sure other people don't get sick
we're talking about the parts of their
[ __ ] body
you stupid [ __ ]
liberty
liberty
liberty is
the the freedom and the right for the
woman to decide what she is and what she
is not gonna do with her uterus
rather she chooses
to take some form of birth control and
plan her parenthood
or if she chooses to have a baby
or in the case in rape incest and un
unplanned pregnancies has the ability to
plan for her family and her body and her
life
liberty you stupid [ __ ]
and i think
i think
these
you al-qaeda american taliban
these these these [ __ ] spread necks
showing up
at these these school board meetings
these [ __ ]
they saw a real protest last summer
with george floyd and black lives matter
they're about to see a bigger coalition
even rain down on their [ __ ] asses
because folks
if they will make sure to strip liberty
from women in texas and god knows what
other state is gonna use this model
if they are willing to do this
they're gonna come after your [ __ ]
liberty not not
not
oh
you're gonna make me wear a mask so i
don't get people sick
this is nuts in germany
i'm talking about real fascism here
real fascism where they're controlling
your [ __ ] body
they're controlling it not like not like
you claim the vaccine
because you have a choice with the
vaccine see you can get it or not get it
now not getting it that choice may have
consequences the same way as getting the
vaccine has consequences like not
getting covered and not having to
[ __ ] down three boxes of horse paste
a week that consequence you know that's
why i took the vaccine because i really
don't want to gobble up a bunch of
[ __ ] horse paste and then take a
sheep dip bath i really i'm not into
that so that's why i got the vaccine so
those consequences are on my side
and a woman has the same liberty and the
same choice as you have with the vaccine
don't you [ __ ] see it
don't you see it
or does that [ __ ] dewormer [ __ ] with
your sight too
because speaking of these protesters
and they're not protesters they're
[ __ ] domestic terrorism it's domestic
terrorism they're calling
they're calling
to terrify the country
to get them to do what they want to do
we are at the intersection and i've seen
and i've posted on twitter
plenty of these [ __ ] videos
you guys have seen these
a white dude most time they kind of look
like me unfortunately
a white dude
yelling and screaming like i do just on
the other side of things
nonsense q anon
trump humping
maga anti-backs anti-mask nonsense
school board meetings
uh
the protest of school boards
uh anti-backs anti-mass rallies
we
in this country
are at the intersection
of wrestlemania and real life folks
that's where we're at
we are at the intersection
of wrestlemania
in real life
and the feed store
is right there on the [ __ ] corner all
stocked up with ivermecton
these people are going to school board
meetings they're terrorizing the school
boards
they're firing
they're firing administrators because
these administrators are putting in
policies to protect their students
to not get sick
little kids little kids can't get
vaccinated you fools
and teenagers a lot of them aren't
vaccinated because you parents are
[ __ ] dumbasses
so there's a lot of [ __ ] human beings
in these schools that are not vaccinated
and not protected from the virus
that with this delta variant is
affecting younger and younger and
younger
people
rather it be great school high school or
college
now most of these colleges have got off
their asses and they have a way
to get these people vaccinated because
most of them by the time they get to
college they're 18 they have the consent
to get a vaccination they don't have to
wait on their dumbass spread neck parent
to give them permission to get a
vaccination
so a lot of these colleges are doing the
right thing
but some of these [ __ ] states
the only protections they have is mass
mandates
that's the mitigation tactics and
protection they have for not just the
students but the [ __ ] staff as well
just because you're vaccinated doesn't
mean it's a hundred percent unless
unless
the entire population around you is
vaccinated
and there is a minute chance of spread
of that virus to them or to you
so the only way to mitigate that is to
take the mitigation tactics that we know
that work because they worked last year
and we know they work with this variant
just like they did the last variant
is to make sure you're not sneezing
coughing and talking on someone
that it's airborne folks comes out of
your [ __ ] nose and your mouth and
that's how it infects someone else and
that's how you get infected
it really is not rocket surgery okay
okay you [ __ ] worm eater
warm eater
paste eater call it
they need
dewormed or de-brained
they need one or the other
you [ __ ] paste eater it it's that
simple
when you're talking are you coughing or
sneezing it comes out of here
onto you just like this onto you
right and then if you do it it's on to
me
so when you when you put something over
your [ __ ] face
it helps to protect that
that way if you're infected or i
infected or both infected we don't
infect each other that way you don't
infect others
how in the [ __ ] hell have we been
doing this a year and a half and i have
to sit here and explain this to you dumb
[ __ ]
children aren't vaccinated they can't be
young children under 12.
and most children over 12
a lot of them are not because their
parents are [ __ ] boneheads again
we have to protect them from getting
sick
we have to do that
i mean they're kids what the [ __ ] you
gonna do you're gonna leave them to
slaughter
you know
like like joe biden did all those afghan
people
all those women and children over there
left them to slaughter
you can't even you can't even put
together that that children need to be
wearing cloth bass to make sure they
don't get each other sick because you
dumb [ __ ] aren't getting
vaccinated
because if we rewind the clock here and
go back to april when the administration
opened up vaccines to everyone in the
entire [ __ ] country and you and your
[ __ ] children who are 12 and over
would have wouldn't got vaccinated when
you were [ __ ] supposed to
we would not be in this goddamn [ __ ]
mess that you're complaining about
you understand that right
or should i spell it out to you
it really is [ __ ] frustrating to
watch
someone go into a [ __ ] school board
meeting grab a microphone
say all kinds of [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
like q and on slam poetry
and then blame it blame it on the school
board that they have to have a mass
mandate to keep kids safe when that
person that's spewing their [ __ ]
germs and their [ __ ] disease all over
everybody in the [ __ ] room the reason
why is because you're a [ __ ] bonehead
and you didn't do what you were supposed
to do to keep the disease at bay
now we have to go to it
extraordinary lengths to keep kids safe
because you're a dumbass
just like when you want to go get your
horse paced and you have to have your
horse passport
you got to go to your neighbor and get
you a picture with their horse hey my
horse
now i can go get my paste
do they brush their teeth with this do
they eat this do they put it on a
[ __ ] hoagie
i'm trying to figure out what they do i
mean do they do they did they just spoon
it out like it's like it's [ __ ]
peanut butter
are we gonna have flavored horse paste
too i mean these people you know they
probably want some variety
like blueberry strawberry
you know nut butter flavored
i don't know i'm just
i'm just rolling out ideas here maybe
the horse pace manufacturers can get a
hold of this show and you know get some
good ideas on how to market this stuff
to
[ __ ] queuing honors
just saying
so back to the school board meeting so
we have these boneheads saying these
bone-headed things
in a bone-headed way in a bone-headed
fashion
for a bone-headed amount of time
and then the school board's like no
we're gonna we're gonna do mask what
you're saying is [ __ ] stupid
because we're gonna try to protect your
children who are coming to our school
and that's what we're gonna do
and most most places are doing this
now i do have some teacher friends and i
have asked them and some of them say
well
yeah
we're kind of lackadaisical
about the whole mass thing but uh one
did tell me today that their school has
several cases
that are being
quarantined and the school
administration saying hey if you don't
want to be quarantined put your [ __ ]
mask on because the state law in that
state says if you have the mask on and
someone around you has coveted you do
not have to quarantine so if you don't
want a quarantine put your [ __ ] mask
on so they're trying to do anything to
convince these these people to put their
mask on
put their [ __ ] mask on and keep them
on
and all the while all the while we have
the gqp
the american taliban
trying to
to
instigate these domestic terrorists
because that's that's what's really
happening here folks these people are
believing everything that they post on
everything that they see on facebook to
get all riled up about the bad the
the vaccine and mask
i i wanted to combine those two words
maybe we should come up with a word that
that is vaccine and mask on one work
that out twitter get that going for me
but the thing is is that they're
the only reason why trumpism is
continuing
this just queuing on maga trump pumping
garbage the school board
city council
vaccine passport anti-vaxx anti-mass
rally [ __ ] is happening
is because they're trying
to keep support
of these [ __ ] crazies
trying to keep them in the political
fray at the intersection of wrestlemania
in real life
you know because they started to exit a
little bit and they're like oh [ __ ] we
really need to get them back here let's
let's feed them horse pace and feed them
lies that'll get them back here and it
did
it did get him back there quick fast and
in a [ __ ] hurry here we are at
trumpism again
and it's domestic domestic terrorism is
what it is i mean jesus christ you have
you have people who running for public
office that are saying that they're
going to physically go remove
school board members that those school
board members should be terrified of
them
terrorified
do you see that do you see the root word
there
terrify you should be terrified of us
terrorism
you see how that works there's like a
root word there
when you were using fear for someone's
life or their physical well-being or
their family or their community's
physical well-being or their family or
communities lives that's called
terrorism
and it's domestic because it's
for us by us
that's what it is you stupid
[ __ ] you are the american
christian taliban
y'all kaidah
yaw kaida and you have your generals
the al-qaeda generals
in washington dc
there's a whole [ __ ] list of these
[ __ ] and the january 6
commission
committee excuse me they wanted a 911
style commission but they couldn't have
that
because that would be bipartisan by god
the american people just might believe
that [ __ ]
now we have the january 6 committee
select committee in the house
and it seems as if
the al-qaeda generals
they're going to have to hand over their
phone records
and their documents
and you have kevin mccarthy yesterday
saying you can't do this it's illegal
for the telecommunications companies to
give congress's records to congress
[ __ ]
and by the way the only thing that the
select committee really did with the
telecommunications companies is said hey
you're going to want to preserve your
records
you're going to want to preserve them
because we're gonna want them
we're gonna request them and if they
won't give them to us we're gonna get
them from you
and this this is not something that
these telecommunication companies don't
know they know that they have to
preserve these records they're not
[ __ ] dumb why do you think they shred
this [ __ ] oh my god
congress is gonna want to subpoena this
stuff let's shred it that's a good idea
it's a good idea
to go against a congressional select
committee subpoena
real boneheaded stuff real republican
stuff there
so kevin mccarthy thinks that uh the
telecommunication companies cannot give
these records to congress which is all
[ __ ] and then he had mo brooks today
on tv well it's not really tv folks
jesus christ it's like i'm saying i'm tv
i'm not tv i'm just a [ __ ] guy
talking into a goddamn microphone so on
newsmax a bunch of people talking in the
microphones mo brooks gets on there and
talks into a microphone and says they do
not have probable cause
they don't have probable cause to get my
records and the other thing that he says
which is really significant i think if
you go watch the clip and i've got it
posted on my twitter you can find it
there
uh
mo brooks says
that they want the text message they're
talking about text messages and he's
talking about text messages to the
president of the united states which was
donald trump and on january 6.
well i don't know if there's text
messages and i don't know if if there
was any ever text messages
and i don't know what they say there may
be things in there that could be
misconstrued because they're private but
that's why they can't get them is
because they're private
that's what mo brooks is claiming that
there's no probable cause here because
these are not public these are not
public text messages and public phone
calls these are private what the [ __ ] is
a public phone call what the [ __ ] is a
public text message what the [ __ ] is
that can you figure that out you tell me
type it in the comments
what is a public text message
if it ain't private what the [ __ ] is it
what the hell is a text message if it
ain't [ __ ] private
hey
text messages in the entire [ __ ]
country is there a text message
billboard somewhere that i'm unaware of
is there
i'm wondering
your text messages are essentially
private
and i think he's saying it's on a
private phone is what he's trying to say
it's not a government-owned phone it's a
private phone which doesn't make a
difference hella beans where the
difference anyways
a crime is a crime is a crime rather you
committed on a phone that the government
pays for or that you pay for it's a
[ __ ] crime
what
ah i committed crime on my private phone
so you can't do [ __ ] about it
what the [ __ ] are you talking about and
just to make it fair mo brooks if you
really want to make it fair
what we can do
is we can get out the sedition sniffing
dogs if you want you know to sniff out
that sedition just like you do drug dogs
around a [ __ ] car and have them hit
on a car so you can pull the black dude
out of the car and beat the holy living
[ __ ] out of him and probably shoot and
kill him maybe even lean on him and kill
him with your knee ah that'd be a good
wouldn't it
[ __ ]
yeah that's what we should do get this
get the sedition sniffing dogs after
these son of a [ __ ] for their private
communications
let me tell you something about private
communication folks
and how how mo brooks and the republican
party
feel about private communications in
this country especially when it comes to
[ __ ] terrorism
okay are you ready for this this this
you it may we may not remember this but
there was a [ __ ] mass shooting
several years ago and i didn't look up
the date i apologize but it was in san
bernardino california you guys remember
this
it was a husband and a wife team
and they decided to have someone buy
them guns
and they went into their workplace and
they mowed down a bunch of people
now
they were of muslim descent they were
muslims
so obviously obviously the gqp the
republican party everyone had them
deemed up
deemed up as terrorist immediately
because of their the sound of their name
and the color of their skin
now i also remember there was something
very significant about the san
bernardino shootings
if you remember
apple and the government were kind of at
war with each other over those people's
phones
and the reason why they're at war with
each other
is because the government
wanted a back door
to their iphones
and apple told them to go [ __ ]
themselves we do not have a back door
to that iphone and even if we did we
would not give it to you they even went
to court over this [ __ ]
well guess who is the most vocal
the most vocal
about making sure that the government
got into those iphones do you remember
who it was
it wasn't the [ __ ] crowd screaming
about freedom and liberty and rights at
the school board meetings
one that crowd
they weren't screaming about freedom
and privacy
and liberty and rights
they weren't screaming about it then
like they're screaming about [ __ ]
now
it's the exact opposite
as a matter of fact i would almost bet
that someone who takes horse paste
was a hundred percent for
the government getting into those
iphones
maybe not a complete hundred percent but
it was pretty goddamn close i bet
now
let's go back
let's go back to the al-qaeda generals
the sedition sisters
that are worried about their phone logs
worried about the text message logs
and i would say
that they should probably should be
pretty [ __ ] worried if there's
anything about anything that even sniffs
like sedition than there
if if it's is if it's as secure as matt
gats venmo they're completely [ __ ]
that's right
if they if they couldn't figure out how
to use a burner
when they're committing federal crimes
and [ __ ] sedition
that is that is
completely within congress's power to
expel them for
then yeah
they should be worried because i see
[Music]
the crystal ball coming here
where
members of congress now you know there's
a big list of names right now and i
don't know if all those names will end
up being the
the final list of of sedition sisters
but the al-qaeda generals really look
like mo brooks paul gozar
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
uh madison cawthorne
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
matt gets i mean the list goes on and on
here and i wouldn't be surprised if
there wasn't senators involved because
if you remember uh back in i think it
was about february march josh hawley was
questioning uh christopher wray the fbi
director about metadata that might have
been collected from members of congress
he seemed a little interested in that
i did a video about it i should have
pulled it but maybe i'll repost it next
week
but there's a list of these sedition
sisters
and my guess is
my guess is
is that there's going to be a an
official list of sedition sisters that
the congress is gonna vote to expel
because my guess is
is that the evidence that's in the phone
records and then the text messaging logs
and really the videotape of these
[ __ ] boneheads running around giving
these people tours of the capital
telling them where to go and how to go
and when to go and where the enemy will
be
my guess is
with the evidence that's going to be
laid out and the testimonies that are
going to happen and the pleading of the
fifth that is going to ensue
because i i i my guess is
if these congress people don't go in
front of congress and lie which is also
a [ __ ] crime is also me
a reason to be expelled
from your congressional seat
my guess is is that they'll plead the
fifth
so they're either gonna tell the truth
that's a three that's the three [ __ ]
choices you got
tell the truth
lie
or plea the fifth now if they plea the
fifth that's because they don't want to
self-incriminate
that means
it's a possible federal crime that
happened
possible where congress could give a
referral or you know the fbi could watch
the tape of them saying they did a
federal crime
under oath in a committee hearing of the
january 6th select committee
but
i think we're gonna get a list an
official list of sedition sisters
that will be voted on to be expelled now
rather that happens uh this year next
year whenever that happens because folks
that that's that's the
uh the fireworks show that we're waiting
for here is 2022 the election year the
election cycle we thought 2016 was bad
and we thought 2020 was bad
by god 2022 is gonna be a [ __ ] the
grand finale
the grand
finale
so
my advice to you
out there if you want to prepare
to make sure we resist things like the
law in texas
to make sure that these seditious
[ __ ] in congress do not keep
their seats
or are expelled
to make sure that we can end the falcon
the [ __ ] filibuster for good
and pass
voting rights rather be for the people
act or one of the john lewis voting
rights acts
if you want to make sure that we
continue the infrastructure bill
if
universal health care is very very very
important to you
i would go register to vote
and i would be finding
i would be finding right now the people
that you're going you're going to
consider voting for
because there may be several people in
your district that you may be voting for
are had the chance to vote for
to have the candidate of your choice
my guess is is that you're also going to
want to pay attention to school boards
city councils
hoas and these people they're they're
going to take over hoas and
i don't know road districts all kinds
they're [ __ ] nuts
the point is
the best way
the best way to save our democracy and
keep your liberty through your freedoms
and your rights
is devote
vote vote vote like your life depends on
it and other people's lives like your
children and your neighbors because it
[ __ ] does
it [ __ ] does at this point
they are not gonna let this trumpism go
they see it as a as a [ __ ] road map
to fascism and that's ultimately what
they want that's what they want
they want a caliphate
they want a religious caliphate here in
the united states of america just like
we gave the taliban and maybe
maybe that's the point maybe that's why
they're so [ __ ] upset about joe biden
leaving afghanistan
if you think about it really
maybe it's jealousy
maybe they're jealous that the right
wingers in the taliban get their own
[ __ ] caliphate
and by god they don't get to have their
own [ __ ] caliphate if we don't get to
have our fascist caliphate
and if we're gonna do that we're gonna
take away women's uteruses
we're gonna
we're gonna make sure kids get sick
and we're to eat horse pace god damn it
horse pace sandwiches for everyone
the american
taliban
y'all kaida
we are at the intersection
of wrestlemania and real life and this
is what the [ __ ] it looks like
it doesn't it's not gonna quit
so we can't quit
we got to make 22 count
vote blue and 22
vote
vote
vote vote [ __ ] vote
school board city council
trash committee
senator congress person
whoever the [ __ ] it is
find that candidate if you don't have a
[ __ ] candidate either run or find
someone
but let's just do this whole democracy
thing can we
let's do democracy and get rid of the
[ __ ] american taliban it's enough
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them